toujours prévu donc est adopté ce matin
au conseil des ministres la
réglementation de l'accès de la
publicité sur les radios libres qui
avait été annoncé par le président de la
république lors de sa dernière
conférence de presse de presse parlant
en fait sur le terrain la publicité a
déjà fait son entrée sous diverses
formes comme l'a constaté bruno le dreff
lors de son enquête le lot était dans la
bergerie depuis longtemps déjà la
publicité sur la bande fm ce n'est pas
vraiment nouveau mais aujourd'hui c'est
autorisé finies les galères des
parrainages sponsoring et autres publi
reportage
vive la pub vive le commerce les radios
locales privées ont plus de 5 millions
d'auditeurs régulier un auditoire de
qualité john disposant d'un bon pouvoir
d'achat une cible convoitée par les
publicitaires le temps des
démonstrations de force est donc venu on
rassemble ses auditeurs dans de grandes
fêtes
il faut impressionner les annonceurs
l'autorisation de la publicité va devant
nous apporter l'indépendance la
véritable indépendance nous allons
dépendre que de nous et de nos nouveaux
auditeurs et ça nous permettent de
devenir encore plus professionnelle
certaines ont la possibilité de demeurer
associative et pour celles qui
choisissent la le statut commercial et
bien les règles de la libre concurrence
ont joué et la loi du marché
les meilleurs évidemment émergents pour
être toujours plus fort il faut des
alliés énergie vend donc son label à des
radios de province comme ici scoop à
lyon le calcul assurer aux annonceurs
des campagnes nationales sur les radios
locales pour les petites comme si elles
fm toujours à lyon la concurrence va
être difficile la radio a besoin de 10
millions de centimes par mois
actuellement la publicité lui en
rapporte 4 il n'est pas sûr que la
nouvelle loi améliore cette situation
contrairement à ce qu'on peut penser
nous ciel fm à lyon l'équipe on a un peu
bu le champagne pas du tout parce que on
se rend compte qu'il n'ya pas dans une
ville comme lyon 36 places pour des
radios commerciales
il y en avoir trois ou quatre au maximum
et il est extrêmement difficile pour une
radio moyenne comme si elles fm de
pouvoir se hisser dans l'est
les quatre premières places il existe
aujourd'hui 865 radio comme si elles fm
selon les professionnels de la publicité
seuls 150 200 d'entre elles
bénéficieront de la manne publicitaire
un marché de 100 millions de francs par
an ce sera un monde extrêmement vivant
et il n'est pas impossible que les 150 à
200 radios dont je parle ne sont pas
toujours les mêmes c'est à dire que là
nous allons assister à des cycles de vie
extrêmement variables des stations
il ya celles qui sauront apporter
quelque chose à leurs auditeurs se
maintiendront d'autres se renouvelleront
d'autres mourront et de nouvelles
mettront les radios qui opteront pour le
statut commercial vont devoir convaincre
les annonceurs de leurs capacités
d'imagination de leur rigueur de leur
audience
mais pour conserver cette audience elles
devront aussi se défier de la publicité